[Music]
saturated the guns tonight won't protect
us from the coming of the dark I'm the
only one left roland deschain comes from
a sort of legacy of gunslingers who were
put in place to protect the dark tower
from the mana black
roland was the last in that line the
Dark Tower was at the center of the
universe the tower protects our world
from chaos and death if it falls it will
be unleashed
the man in black he's the people in this
battle of good versus evil
he's like the devil isn't he no he's
worse I need to bring down the town you
can't stop what's coming death always
wins I'm sworn to defend the town I'll
stop at nothing to protect it
Rowland is actually the only one that
could bring me down darkness is your
weapon guns of mine I started the dark
color
I really saw the gunslinger as dark
tower has always been really important
to me and to see the gunslinger come to
life and film with eat yourself up it's
really incredible to have guns and
bullets in your world you're gonna like
earth a lot alright let's go
I do not hang with my hand I aim at my
eye
I can I shoot with my hand as you live
my mind I did not kill with my god
iq of my arm
the thousands of generations the
gunslingers were Knights just want to
protect us from the count of the dark
seas visions as you call them what do
you see
they see a tower the man in black and
the comes to you just streams
they're not real Jake if you know the
world out there no threes
Oh will you chew here at gunslinger
right there are no clean slate not
anymore
why does the man in black want to
destroy the tower the tower protects
both our worlds if it falls hell will be
unleashed
he's like the devil isn't he no he's
worse you can't stop what's coming death
always wins your world might be gone but
mine isn't
you let that telephone booths of people
die
guns and bullets in the world you're
gonna like earth a lot that's right
let's go
you clawing your way out of the darkness
did she tell the kid whoever walks with
you guys by my hand
I will kill him for both of us you're
not aiming at my head
arranged with his hand has forgotten the
face of his father I aim at my eye
not shoot with my hand
especially my mind
I did not kill with my gun
[Applause]
[Music]
I killed my heart
[Music]
[Music]